[Music]  in today's eight on your side the best  way is to navigate a gap year for your  university-bound son or daughter  kovid changed in-person learning plans  for several colleges and universities  across the u.s this year making students  rethink if a remote education was worth  full tuition price  some students capitalized on the shift  to save money and withdrew from school  until further notice  now the trick is to find something to  engage in that will keep your skills  sharp and  have you ready for the next step what  students are really interested  in right now are can i take these short  expedited intensive courses before the  summer  you know in the spring and the summer  times head so i can transfer those into  that institution  and coming up at five we'll chat with  the company about ways to knock out some  basic college courses at a reduced price  also when the best time to apply for an  internship is denise